As we've discussed in previous classes and offer may typically be revoked at any
time before the offeree accepts the offer.
Today,
we discussed an exception to that rule by looking at a 1958 California case
Drennan versus star paving Drennan.
A general contractor prepared a bid for construction contract before submitting
his bid.
Drennan had solicited other bids from several subcontractors and the defendant's
star paving submitted the lowest bid for the paving.
Subcontract Drennan use star Paving's bid to calculate,
calculate his overall bid on the construction contract.
Drennan was awarded the construction contract and after Drennan won the bid,
but before he was able to notify star paving,
star paving discovered that it's,
that it's bid of $7,131 and 60 cents was an error and informed Drennan that it
would not perform for less than $15,000.
Drennan ended up engaging another paving subcontractor for $10,948 and sued star
paving for the difference of $3,187.
This is the difference between the defendants bid and the costs that Drennan
actually had to pay a replacement paving subcontractor.
The trial court found for the plaintiff Drennan and the incident court affirmed.
So the central issue in the case is this,
did the plaintiffs to reliance make the defendant's offer irrevocable?
And the court here found yes.
Uh,
the reliance did make the offer.
It revokable star paving argued that there was no enforceable contract between
the parties on the ground,
that it made a revokable offer and revoked it before plaintiff communicated his
acceptance.
However,
the court in an opinion written by one of the most famous a state court justices
in our nation's history,
uh,
justice trainer disagreed,
justice trainer pointed to a promissory Estoppel provision of the restatement,
the famous section 90,
which says under the first restatement that a promise which the promise or
should reasonably expect to induce action or forbearance of a definite and
substantial character on the part of the promise he and which does induce such
action or forbearance is binding if injustice can be avoided only by enforcement
of the promise.
Since the defendant reasonably relied on star paving's bid to commit itself to
the construction contract at a price incorporating star paving's bid star
paving's offer could not be revoked because injustice would otherwise result.
Okay,
so in Drennan,
the court relied on section 90 of the restatement and you may recall section 90
of the restatement from our earlier discussions of promissory Estoppel in
earlier classes.
Can you remember what his promissory Estoppel
under the doctrine of promissory Estoppel,
if a promise see reasonably relies on a promise and changes her position
accordingly,
the promise may be binding even without consideration if justice so requires,
remember rickets versus scar thorn where grandfather promise to pay his
granddaughter $2,000 and re and in response,
the granddaughter quit her job
even though justice trainer used section 90 to hold that star paving's offer.
Was he a revokable?
The facts in Drennan don't quite fit.
Promissory Estoppel applies when a promise he relies on an unconditional
promise,
but in Drennan,
star paving only made an offer to enter into a bilateral contract but never
promised to keep that offer open and offer as a kind of conditional promise,
which is conditioned on the other side's return promise.
It can be argued that it was unreasonable for Drennan to rely on the conditional
promise,
especially when Drennan could have made it unconditional.
By accepting to resolve this dilemma,
justice Traynor held that quote,
reasonable reliance resulting in a foreseeable prejudicial change of in position
affords a compelling basis also for implying of subsidiary promise not to revoke
an offer for a bilateral contract.
In other words,
a sub contractors bid creates an implicit subsidiary promise not to revoke the
offer if it becomes part of the winning bid
trainer.
His reasoning is now enshrined in a separate section of the restatement section
87 two which reads and offer which the offer or should reasonably expect to
induce action or forbearance of a substantial character by the offeree before
acceptance and which does induce such action or for Barron's is binding as an
option contract to the extent necessary to avoid injustice.
Consider the following.
Hypothetical oil lease owner offered to enter a far amount agreement with oil
driller.
The offer stated that it was era vocable for a period of 120 days plus a 30 day
extension driller who was to accept the offer by drilling on a designated
parcel,
paid nothing for the option before acceptance driller and reliance on the option
drill the test well,
uh,
on another parcel,
the data from this test drilling would help to uh,
to evaluate whether to accept the offer before acceptance.
However,
owner attempted to change the terms of the offer based on the holding and
Drennan versus star paving.
Can owner change the terms of the offer at this stage?
No.
The drillers reliance upon the written option promise made the offer irrevocable
and driller could create a contract on the original terms of the offer.
This example is based on a real case strata production versus mercury
exploration.
Another way to think about this case is by asking who should bear the risk of a
subcontractor error.
The holding in this case puts the risk of error on the subcontractor.
This seems reasonable.
It forces the subcontractor to internalize the cost of its own mistakes,
which creates an incentive for the subcontractor to be more careful.
The general contractor on the other hand,
doesn't have much control over whether it's subcontractors make mistakes in
their bids.
If the cost of mistake was shoulder by the general contractor,
it might have to add a premium to its bid to compensate itself or the occasional
mistake by a subcontractor.
This in turn would increase the cost of construction contracts.
In other words,
the subcontractor is probably the least cost avoider in this case,
and so should bear the risk.
The court seems to recognize this principle when it says quote as between the
subcontractor who made the bid and the general contractor who reasonably relied
on it.
The loss resulting from the mistake should fall on the party who caused it.
Now there are circumstances.
However,
when the general contractor might be the least cost avoider.
For example,
if there's a large mistake in the offered bid such as leaving off a zero
creating a bid 10 times smaller than the next lowest bid,
the general contractor should easily recognize that this is a mistake and maybe
pointed out if this had happened in Drennan,
it may have changed the outcome.
The court specifically considered this point,
but found that the general contractor quote had no reason to know that the
defendant had made a mistake in submitting it's bid
under Drennan.
A subcontractors bid becomes an era vocable offer when the general contractor
relies on it in a winning bid.
However,
the general contractor is still not accepted.
The subcontractors bid and might solicit a new round of subcontractor bids,
something that is called bid shopping justice trainer was to point out quote,
a general contractor is not free to delay acceptance after he has been awarded
the general contracted in the hope of getting a better price,
nor can he reopened bargaining with the subcontractor and at the same time claim
a continuing right to accept the original offer.
So the subcontractors offer is only a revokable if the general contractor does
not misuse it's option power.
Since the overall project contract has already been awarded at this point,
only the general contractor,
not the project owner,
will profit from this bid shopping.
Recognizing this potential for abuse.
In 1963 the California legislature adopted a subletting and sub Contracting Fair
Practices Act.
The statute provides that the general contractor bidding on quote,
any public work or improvement must disclose in its bid.
The name of any subcontractor who's bid is incorporated into an exceeds 1% of
the price of the general contractor's bid.
The statute further provides that a general contractor who's bid on a public
project is accepted,
shall not replace the subcontractor listed in his bid with another subcontractor
except under certain conditions.
And with the awarding the authorities consent.
So what are the consequences of the statute?
Since the general contractor cannot bargain with subcontractors after winning
the bid,
it must make an all or nothing choice beforehand and it would induce all
competition beforehand to better solicit a number of bids.
Given that expos competition may not redound to the public buyer's benefit,
the statutes make some sense if it leads to more x anti-competition for
subcontracts.
But in some circumstances,
generals may not have time for prebid competition and the statute may not allow
subs to exercise,
uh,
some market power.
It's difficult to assess where whether this merely protects subs or create some
inappropriate market power.
So for subs,
sub contractors,
the asymmetry created by the holding and Drennan could also be modified by
contract.
The,
for starters,
the court states quote had star Paving's bid expressly stated or clearly implied
that it was revokable at any time before acceptance.
We would treat it accordingly,
unquote.
In other words,
the holding in Drennan that his subcontractors bid becomes an irrevocable offer
if it be comes part of the winning bid is merely a default rule and may be
contracted around by the subcontractors in their initial offer.
Alternatively,
a bitter with a strong bargaining power might insist upon a conditional
bilateral contract.
I will bid and do the job only if you promise to award the contract to me.
If you use my bid as a part of your winning overall,
a submission.
This strategy creates a bilateral contract,
which is immediately binding,
but which only has to be performed if the general wins.
The general.